happy friday today we're talking about
when you can finally get your hands on
that gta trilogy remaster how playing
back for blood solo might affect your
progression just a little bit
and assassin's creed producer jade
raymond is teasing a new game my name is
devonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
so following weeks of rumor and
speculation rockstar games has
officially announced the new grand theft
auto remaster package featuring grand
theft auto 3 grand theft auto vice city
and grand theft auto san andreas it's
called grand theft auto trilogy the
definitive edition and it comes with
updated and revised versions of those
three games the bundle will be available
on ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x and s
nintendo switch and on pc through the
rockstar games launcher later this year
a mobile edition for ios and android is
also coming in the first half of 2022.
however pricing wasn't announced there
were no images or videos of the trilogy
and a specific release date was not
given what rockstar did say is that you
can expect more details on the games in
the package in the coming weeks
and they're removing the existing
versions of gta 3 vice city and san
andreas from digital stores beginning
next week i am so glad that the rumors
were true and this remaster is real but
it did bring up the question
where's gta 6
following rockstar's announcement of the
trilogy the definitive edition twitter
was flooded with memes and gifts of fans
all over wondering
where's gta 6 and
will it ever arrive i'm going to tell
you a secret if you really want gta 6
stop playing gta 5
but ok back for blood is a social game
and developer turtle rock studios
doesn't want players to forget that
while playing a campaign match with
others will let players earn supply
points which can be used to purchase
cards and cosmetics the game's solo mode
totally cuts players off from all
rewards
the first time players try to pick out
what zombie slaying experience they want
in the game's hub area ford hope they're
greeted with three options campaign puts
players in a match with anyone in their
party or random players and swarm mode
is the game's take on left 4 dead pvp
solo campaign is about as
straightforward as it gets letting
players tackle back for blood's four act
campaign with bots anyone looking for
some zombie slaying alone time will have
to do it knowing that they won't be
getting any rewards for their hard
blood-soaked work
a screen pops up as soon as players
choose solo campaign detailing
everything they won't earn by
progressing through the game this way
the one upside of solo campaign is that
players get to use any solo card decks
that they make which have access to a
wide variety of cards compared to a
regular campaign deck
producer jade raymond has teased the
first game from her new studio haven
which has aligned itself exclusively
with playstation and you might need a
whole lot more hard drive space raymond
said haven't's first game is going to be
quote really ambitious and showcase what
the ps5 is capable of she also teased
that the game's file size might be truly
massive and that game streaming
technology might play a role in its
execution with the potential of
producing a game with a terabyte's worth
of data raymond is taking learnings from
her time at google on the stadia team
and applying them to haven apparently
it's currently unclear how much local
hard drive space this will actually take
up when games like microsoft flight
simulator use two petabytes of
geographical data but most of it is
streamed to your computer
raymond isn't ready to share specifics
about haven's first game just yet but
she teased that it will have a
significant social element she said
quote the pandemic has proven that
gameplay is the social glue that binds
communities especially for the younger
generation this is what you do and how
you make friends and hang out that is
something that we really want to build
and design for haven's first game is a
new ip that will seem to have an
emphasis on social elements
self-expression and remix concepts
in terms of signing with playstation for
haven's first game raymond said sony
stood out as a company that quote really
understands the creative process
she also mentioned how sony is known to
give its game studios autonomy which was
a big attractor
but all right hit the comment section
right now right this second and let me
know what you're getting into this
weekend me i'm going to be partying at a
bat mitzvah all right and then i got a
plane to catch
so
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you